comment un gourou de l'UT peut-il markula Tyga da
mmm parles-tu de ce cheval pourquoi suis-je
couvert de terre je t'ai enterré pourquoi suis-je
vivant
huit hommes ont écrit dans le canyon j'ai creusé sept
tombes le cheval dit que tu es l'esprit Walker
homme qui a été de l'autre côté  et un
homme de retour qui ne peut pas être tué au
combat quelque chose de très mal avec ce
cheval
si nous sommes ensemble nous sommes à la justice
justice c'est ce que je cherche les
gens de Kemosabe pensent que tu es mort mieux vaut rester comme
ça tu ne portes que de la masse il vient un
moment  quand un homme bon doit porter des masques d'
accord faisons ça
toi